okay thank you for coming to my talk if
you haven't already follow me on Twitter
look that makes me happy if you want to
read about Who I am what I do I have a
website for that the important thing for
this talk is to know that I'm a
programmer who's spent a lot of time
reading other people's code and not
always enjoying that I'm very happy to
see that so many of you skipping the
useful talks and have come to a
different kind of talk because that's
where you are the reason that I got into
this kind of topic thinking about what
code looks like is that I've spent a lot
of time thinking about reading code and
code being maintainable so the serious
thing is a kind of a doing training on
maintainable code this is not that talk
this is something that I started
thinking about when I read this about
how as programmers we spend much more
time reading code than we do writing
code and yet our tools then seem to
acknowledge this at all seem to be
focused on the experience of writing
code it's almost like we're focused on
how nice it is to write code but we
don't really care about the people who
have to read it which would almost make
sense except those people are ourselves
as well you probably even spend more
time reading your own code thinking who
wrote this on what were they thinking
then you do even writing it so one of
the things that I wish I had was code
with better type this is not yet P track
so I did not mean a better type system I
mean code with better type as in
typography as in typewriter this is an
IBM Selectric typewriter from 1961 this
is a pretty advanced typewriter back in
the day this had an innovation it had
one of these so the type head was
colloquially called a golf ball because
it's kind of golf ball-sized and the
innovation was that you could remove it
and replace it with a different one with
a different typeface this typewriter had
45 different typefaces that is very cool
in fact one of those typefaces was
commissioned especially for this
typewriter by IBM and that typeface is
called Korea it was new in 1961 Korea
was designed to work well with
typewriter technology to be clearly
legible to have exaggerated letter
shapes
this was an early focus on usability
before anybody had thought of the term
UX so this was pretty you know state of
the art hardware printing technology but
consumer level printing technology for
the day from 1961 did programmers use
this exciting new hardware technology
for printing code no they did not at the
time code looked like this this is this
is code printed out on a line printer
programmers used line printers which
were nothing more than nothing less than
a crime to typography they were
optimized I think just for speed just
the speed of turning out pages and and
reading this reading this stuff was was
unpleasant and not because this is COBOL
there's nothing intrinsically unpleasant
about that I hear that certainly
unpleasant to write but this was
unpleasant because there's just no
typography going on here no attention to
letter forms and more importantly no
attention to readability and so for me
typography is maybe a little bit about
the beauty of beautiful typefaces but
it's far more about the user experience
about the readability of text in the
correct typeface and type that
communicates the right kind of idea
reading a novel
printed on one of these would just be
unpleasant you wouldn't want to do that
anyway that's 1960s years later a new
technology for for type was introduced
in Windows 3.1 and in Windows 3.1
Microsoft commissioned a new version of
courier called Korea new which would be
the default monoface monoface typeface
in Windows 3.1 but the difference was
that couriers lines are too thick and
for the typeface to be readable at
common sizes on low resolution monitors
that we had in the day
there had to be thinner so that the
strokes the lines would be one pixel
wide that was really part of the Windows
3.1 is that it and because of this
perhaps it became I guess a kind of
default programming font for many people
because it was the default monospace
font so it has become somewhat
associated with code now this is kind of
strange because I mean when balisong
Windows 3.1 came out of course
typewriters are pretty much gone you
know they're now obsolete technology and
people who used to use typewriters and
now using word processors sometimes not
running on Windows 3.1 or sometimes
dedicated hardware and so they've got
things like WYSIWYG front rendering rich
text and where programmers using rich
text for source code no no they were not
because programmers by this point had
caught up with the typewriter area and
were using courier or courier new when
printing code I mean this this is from
much later than the last year that it
was reasonable to be using a typewriter
from a typography point of view it's
just old technology and you would think
that this has completely gone away I
mean I would expect that maybe or what
maybe none of us or maybe only a few
people in the room actually use courier
as the font in their IDE that's not
really the popular thing but it will
still appear especially in printing code
that's especially weird so I mean
perhaps my only claim to fame is this
book about a style of web framework but
the the saddest thing that happened in
the publication of this book was my
failed argument with the publisher about
printing the source code examples and so
this Scala code was printed in Korean
ooh which is appalling and they refused
to use a proper font they refused to use
something that would be less ugly
because Korea is let's face it ugly and
something that would maybe be more
elegant take up less space and Korea is
very wide we have to format the code
examples to maximum fifty-five columns I
mean that's horrible because I like long
variable names it was really sort of
unpleasant
but they insisted and it's just not only
deeply ironic because not only ugly but
also ironic because it's a book for
print you know I've got paper copies of
this book and in print
none of the constraints that applied to
Korea or to Korea knew were relevant
you see Korea knew had Korea had to work
on a typewriter Korea knew had to work
on low resolution displays but in print
you have thousands of dots per inch you
have high resolution printing you can
use any type face you like you don't
have those you don't need those
compromises and so there's something
cultural going on for no good technical
reason we're using a typeface that was
designed with compromises in mind when
these compromises are no longer
necessary that may be sad but as I said
we probably don't use Korea in our in
our IDs in our text editors I would say
mandatory audience participation sorry
put your hand up if you use a different
font when you write code if you don't
use career indeed almost everybody maybe
even everybody because we have new fonts
so we have new fonts but you know new
fonts have cropped up occasionally over
the years but we have also you know in
as the decades passed by something much
more exciting we got color now I mean we
didn't get color straightaway as
programmers this is a late 1960s Sony
television now I'm pretty old but I'm
not old enough to actually you know had
one of these at home this is from 1969
and you know color makes a big
difference to presenting information I
mean if you have something complex like
I don't know source code maybe that's
useful thing indeed the first time I had
color on my computer was when I was a
teenager I had one of these 1982 model
Sinclair's that expectrum though this
had color 1982 programmers didn't have
color code in 1982 that came much later
so syntax highlighting was the
you know the next big innovation the the
earliest report I've heard of syntax
highlighting is version 7.0 of turbo
Pascal in 1992
so only ten years later only ten years
after miles of expectrum
we had syntax highlighting in code and
syntax highlighting is indeed these days
pretty much universal when you're
reading and writing code it's very
useful what an excellent idea this
incidentally is quite an interesting
piece of code developed from a wikipedia
page because it fits on a slide but it's
interesting because although it's quite
short not all of the lines are equally
interesting it's got the most gratuitous
magic number in the history of
programming in the middle of a
floating-point calculation and with some
appropriate comments even had comments I
don't know maybe the comments are more
more shocking that there are comments in
this code but if you if you're if you
need to understand this code you know
you should maybe start in the middle
maybe you shouldn't you know read it top
to bottom you should you know it takes a
while to digest I mean and there's lots
of interesting things in there to pick
out but the presentation doesn't help
very much I mean we have syntax
highlighting to highlighting to make it
easier to see what's code and what's a
comment but what if there was a better
way to highlight the most interesting
thing about this code other than the
profanity in the comment but this is
almost state of the art incidentally
this is the consular typeface which in
not a coincidence again Microsoft
commissioned for a yet newer type techno
of type of technology from we all got
LCD displays Microsoft invented clear
type clear type is uses sub-pixel font
rendering to give you clearer typefaces
on contemporary monitors and introduced
a bunch of new typefaces whose names
begin with C including consumers very
good coding font and so you know we've
got new fonts so we've got new fonts and
we've got color
one more thing we've got more than that
I mean this is this is already you know
pretty exciting but there's another
innovation and it's it's like all things
in software it's it's new but not at all
new really this has been around for
so we have ligatures now so in
typography and ligature is when you have
two characters that when printed next to
each other would overlap in a kind of
ugly way and so the solution is to make
a new character like the th which the
rendering technology on your computer
will automatically replace the original
two characters with to make the join
nice so technically in the typeface it's
a set for DIF it's a set for a character
image and when you type on no when you
type on a computer the the computer
automatically switches for the combined
character so the th one is quite a
subtle the the F J combination is a
little bit easier to see the dots on the
J on the lowercase J would get in the
way of the ascender the overhanging
ascender on the F and so in the ligature
they're combined and in fact the two
letters are joined together in a
pleasing way in this particular typeface
it just so happens that in in the
English language there was precisely one
word that uses this F J combination and
that's fueled so I guess it's not so
useful in English but it does appear
there maybe in other languages this F J
combination is more common I don't know
and so here is a coding font
Fira code that applies the same
technology in a very creative way it
gets pairs of characters and when you
type them together it replaces it with a
completely different character the front
is based on fear Amano which you see on
the left and so this means that when you
type an exclamation mark are Bank
followed by an equal sign you get a
proper not equal sign like you might
have seen at school when you're a kid
learning mathematics not the ASCII art
characters that we are used to in
programming because most of our symbolic
code is just ASCII bar for proper
mathematical operators and once you've
done this once you've realized that you
can have a proper greater than or equal
sign top right on the slide you can do
much more funky things like have proper
arrows rather than just ASCII are arrows
and you can even do exceedingly cute
things like the funky joined together
www on the bottom
corner and so this if you use this this
this makes your code much nicer so who's
who's already got fear a code installed
okay so that's a minority so the rest of
you this is your lucky day tonight you
can go home and experience the
state-of-the-art in code typography by
downloading this open-source font and
using it for your coding front from now
on don't go to sleep until you have done
this tonight you know install this font
this is maybe the the best thing that's
going to happen to you this week this
will transform your coding experience so
fortunately I have done something useful
this this makes me very pleased so it so
let's recap
you know programming has been a thing
for quite a long time certainly longer
than I've been alive half a century or
more even and over the last 60 years
we've we've had a number of major
innovations in source code typography
you know we've we've got a series of new
typefaces for the latest technology
we've got syntax highlighting sometimes
even including italics and bold and and
we have ligatures so I'm not really
impressed because typography starting
with people chiseling letters forms out
of stone typography is three or four
thousand years old as far as you count
it and in this last 50 years we've
barely touched that in fact you know in
any period there's been more innovation
in typography than we've seen in the
history of our craft so this this is
this is a little bit sad but most of all
it is a huge mystery why as programmers
why as coders users of code a we writing
code that is the only form the only
expression of text in modern
civilization that denies the existence
of tech of typography everything else
every throwaway product brochure
conference badge restaurant menu pays
more attention to layout and typography
than our code
and it's worse because the hardware has
changed again so I mentioned that
console us was introduced when we got
LCD monitors and what's happened since
then well we still have our CD monitors
the resolutions getting better but most
of all they're getting more numerous on
our desk and they're getting wider and
so there was a time I guess in Windows
time we had kind of monitors that look
really square if you see them now in
photos it's kind of weird but now we we
have wider monitors you should have at
least two so if there's anybody here who
doesn't have at least two monitors tell
your boss that I said that you have to
have at least two monitors and that
three will make you a more productive
happier person
so do that but yeah so we have we have
many monitors and this is the this is
the evolution of our current kind of
technology for reading code it's spread
out across our field of vision thing is
you know as a coder writing you know and
maintaining codes that's you know
classes in the codebase what does the
code look like on my monitor well the
code looks like this because every
codebase I've worked on has classes that
are too long and they're this kind of
thin strip would be if I can have filled
them on the monitor so on this slide
that's 538 lines of code I mean it's not
even that much I mean how how long
should a class be I guess you know
classes are supposed to be short ish
right I mean that's what we were told at
school so how short is shortish like is
is 500 cup lines short enough maybe I
mean how many how many classes are there
in your codebase that are more than a
thousand lines long
probably more than there should be
pick a number you know pick a number
what's what's short enough I mean that's
even suppose that you thought 500 lines
were short enough and somehow you can
cope with this how many lines have you
committed to your git repo since the
last time you added a new class probably
more than 500 and yet despite the
preponderance of source files that are
longer than they ought to be and
refactoring that hasn't happened our IDs
don't let us use the space on the
monitor we have bento box ideas you know
that's the user interface paradigm where
you
to carve up the screen into little kind
of rectangular areas and only one of
them has the code in it seems like a
waste and of course you can't see this
much coder once you just see a little
bit you have to scroll around so what
could you do what if you use multiple
columns for the code you know that when
you get to the bottom of the screen
you're just going to start another
column and you can have much more code
on the screen that would be really great
I suppose that you would then scroll
sideways and have additional columns and
if you have more monitors it would just
keep going I'm already liking the idea
this would be great and so this is a
very simple additional idea but nobody's
done this I'm not sure why not
so that's the first thing I want you to
think about why is nobody done this and
then I want all of you all of you to go
to JetBrains booth after this talk and
demand that they add this feature
problem there are problems I mean
obviously you can't find anything here
it's all a bit of a mess so I figured
that you could you could do something
else and I thought you know what if I
just went wild here I mean I've already
broken all of the walls so what if I had
in the same source code more than one
font size and Makemake like the method
signatures bigger now it's starting to
look a bit messy because I've got this
indentation and doesn't line up and and
it's not very tidy and I feel a bit
uncomfortable when it's not tidy but I
figure that if I draw some lines in
between the the columns and in between
the methods then it starts to look a
little bit tidier again I might as well
go all the way because I'm not inventing
this this this visual language this
layout style this is just what
newspapers used to look like so I
apologize for showing Java code had a
thought that conference but you know the
principle is exactly the same and so
what I've done by just doing a few
simple things that somehow have not been
applied to code I have walked this
example of code up to the level of the
first edition of the Oxford Gazette
which was the first newspaper published
in England in 1655 so you know this was
the state of the art or
even the state-of-the-art but just
common practice 360 odd years ago you
know and already like this this is way
beyond what we've ever considered as
programmers this is this is a shame
meanwhile I mean the monitors actually
no we did get color since then they
didn't have color printing in in the
17th century so I guess that's that
anyway meanwhile hardware technology
improving and the monitors just keep
getting wider so wide that they have to
curve because otherwise when you look at
it it's kind of different distances away
I'm not sure if this is good for your
neck working with one of these I'm also
not sure if this is really intended for
gaming or this one which is quite
special that you can rotate this is
really just you know coating monitor for
long classes I want one actually I want
several but but only if I've got columns
right anyway so the simplest kind of
layout would already be quite exciting
what else could we do now it just so
happens that not all software is written
within the same subculture I always work
business software some people write
games so it just so happens that the
fast inverse square root is used in
graphics calculations for 3d graphics
originally comes apparently from Silicon
Graphics workstations back in the 80s
maybe but was was also used in quake
freeze clone open arena which is much
more recent this is uh not much more
than ten years old and so the 3d
graphics routines need very fast
optimized routines for calculating I
guess things like light reflection
angles hence the use of a fast inverse
square root calculation so the usual
aesthetic for code doesn't necessarily
match this or maybe if you're a coder
working in games then you definitely
have a different color theme so I
thought what can I do in typography you
know if I put some code in a
desktop publishing program that gives me
typographical control I could do all
sorts of things I could use more than
one typeface at the same time I could I
could you know use a dark color scheme
just definite have a dark theme if it's
game code right and you know and I could
use heading style I've had it in the
previous example I could I could think
about two-dimensional layout I mean not
just have everything go in a vertical
column and highlight things because
there was one very interesting thing in
that code that I should absolutely
highlight special characters I mean
follow the inspiration of Pharaoh codes
to to use the kind of a cracked
character when it appears and so I just
had a little player I mean this is kind
of where this talk came from as a
conversation in the pub and and I could
I could do this and then I thought you
know this is much more it's much more
it's fun and it's frivolous but what if
what if we could make posters out of
code you know I don't care if you can't
do this automatically I don't care if it
takes a designer a week to make this but
if this is the most interesting code and
the code base I want it a note size on
the wall in the room where we code so
that new people can be told this is
where you start in the code base so I
did all of those things and I even you
know in the big number once you make
text really big the spacing looks a bit
kind of awkward so you know it's a it's
a typography thing to adjust the letter
spacing the kerning between between the
digits in the big number to make it look
a bit more tight and punchy and I'm not
even the designer I mean you know this
is just me messing around of course I
did realize after I'd done this that I
write corporate code I've always done
business-to-business stuff you know this
this game stuff is much less serious in
a way and the code that I'm writing or
maintaining actually usually maintaining
more than writing remember what I said
earlier I'm reading other people's code
not waiting wait just trying to fix
their bugs anyway this code should look
much more corporate so what does
corporate look like for me corporate is
the corporate
port the annual report with the stock
photography and the the glossy cover I
think I think I think code the code from
the newspaper for example should
actually really look something like this
you see I want code to have photography
and a factory being is kind of a serious
grim kind of thing so on a serious
looking at weed control panel photo for
this I want to I want to set the mood
for this class you know it's not just
code I mean there might be some happier
classes somewhere else maybe the
exceptions have you know pictures of
natural disasters or whatever and
actually thinking more about the picture
I mean even before I look at the text so
slight aside because the picture was
nothing to do with typography but you
know graphics and text go together the
picture what if it wasn't just a static
photo I mean if there were test failures
maybe the control panels you know on
fire that would be kind of cool I mean
there's have to be computer graphics but
CGI is pretty cool and I could go off in
a whole direction here about headsets
and you know getting into the code and
walking around some half lifestyle
environment where there are aliens you
know it's the bugs and killing them
anyway let's not do that let's not go
that just just back to the text I guess
it helps if your if your language
supports non-breaking space characters
so you can put spaces in the names
because you know having to kind of you
know put all these long variable names
within one word that's just kind of not
very readable it turns out that if you
put spaces in between words it's easier
to read better user experience or maybe
we should call it better developer
experience DX because you know what take
developers are people to and what else
can we do here so what I've got here is
I've got I've got a whole load of
documentation comments on on the right
which is which is in black and there's
loads of metadata garbage in encode
headers that you don't really need to
see the license the import statement so
that can all go on the left and and I
can actually separate the documentation
comments from the code itself and you
know put them in music columns for that
put line comments you know that that's
the thing that's right aligned in the
first column so what I've done here is
I've picked a differ
layout in typography style I've picked
the textbook as my inspiration for a
corporate code might look like and I
haven't done very much I mean I didn't
go very far with this but just doing
some some simple things probably makes
this much easier to browse much easier
to read one of the things you know and
and if I've got multiple monitors then I
can have my double page layout I don't
know it's kind of pleasing but if what
if you had a real designer what could
they do there's something else that I
did here which I'll have to zoom in so
you can see it properly
we've got high-res monitors now so we're
not quite at the stage where our desktop
monitors are the same resolution as our
phones you know hundreds of dots per
inch but you know there are new monitors
which are more than 200 dots per inch if
you've got decent resolution you can you
certainly don't need monospace fonts
anymore so you can use a proportional
font if you ever want to completely
troll your colleagues especially when
doing pair programming try changing your
programming font to something that's not
mono space you know assuming that works
in your IDE because it doesn't always I
mean some ideas just assume that has to
be a monospaced font the the sky does
not crash civilization does not end it
works maybe you even get to see more
code in a narrower space because
monospaced typeface is a very space
inefficient you know and if your monitor
is clear enough if the resolution is
sharp enough it's going to be just as
legible we don't need those workarounds
anymore we are stuck with 1970s
workarounds that have somehow become
ingrained in our culture generations
later that we don't dare question them
and we complain if people question these
so when you try that experiment I did
this years ago I used verdana it's my
coding font just to see what it would be
like I don't know I was bored or
something it was fine from my point of
view not a biggie it really annoyed my
colleagues so there's I may or may not
be a a bonus from your point of view
it's worth noting that one of the kind
of objections that people make when it
comes to talking about not using
monospace typeface is that the layout
would no longer work push them what do
they mean it turns
that some people you know and I'm
talking to you now line up things
underneath equal signs well that's just
kind of I don't said too bad but it's
just it bad apart from anything else if
you know if you rename a variable which
you should absolutely do when you come
up with a better name it's going to
pollute the diffs of the adjacent lines
because you know the equal signs will
move and then all have to move though
language does this in its format tool
automatically which is a bit of a shame
and so you don't need to do that you
don't need to you know lay things out
like that and in fact the whole idea of
using spaces or tabs I don't care for
layout is also just long because if
you're designing that restaurant menu or
that newspaper front page or a magazine
article and you want something a bit
further to the right you just move it a
bit further to the right or maybe you
type you know plus 1.5 millimeters into
your tool what you don't do is add a
space we can you imagine that in in the
in the design section of the newspaper
somebody saying you know move that to
the left a bit and somebody saying what
space or tap just doesn't make any sense
at all I mean even CSS right so back in
the day before the web there was just go
phone it's all text-based and and then
the very first version of web pages was
already more sophisticated and then
we've got CSS which is based on print
typography and layout and so you know
already by the mid-90s web pages were
more sophisticated than code that took
just a couple of years CSS 1.0 you know
blows away what we can do with code you
know editor so we don't need fixed
ripped typefaces because of high res
monitors so where am I going with this I
think the the ultimate end was to
realize that there's a whole discipline
of typography layout design it's
different thing to programming and it's
different people but I work for product
company and there's no product
department there's an engineering
department where you know we build the
product but there's also a marketing
department where they do things like
market the products with online
materials but also brochures folders you
know little leaflets that the print out
and give out at conferences
and there were designers working for the
marketing department who make those
leaflets the designers are wasted in
marketing the designers should be on the
coding teams and so I believe that we
would be better off if we had a designer
on every development team who instead of
working on a product leaflet or poster
which is going to be thrown away after a
few months because the marketing changes
it's going to instead make leaflets and
posters and coffee table books for the
most important code in the codebase
because that stuff lasts years and the
code may change occasionally so they can
just manually update it you know I think
it would be completely reasonable to say
you know you you recently spent a couple
of days designing a product brochure
well how about you now spend a couple of
days designing an infographic poster for
this which is our most important class
which will be around four years I can't
quite work out how to actually get away
with this
and so this is where I realized that I
probably read some kind of dead end in
my reasoning but although it's obviously
not going to happen anywhere I've ever
worked
it's also not obviously wrong as an idea
and I'm pretty convinced that we're
missing out on this whole discipline in
our code but what is happening what
where is the innovation in code so we
could absolutely have better typography
on the code when we read it better
layout that would help us that would
make it more readable more maintainable
the innovation is not happening where I
was looking it turns out is happening
somewhere else so I'd like to share a
few ideas and a few observations about
where is the innovation in what code
looks like now particularly the
inspiration for from much of this comes
from this presentation called the future
of programming by Brett Richter so who
has seen this presentation online maybe
or even in real life
that was like three people so all of the
rest of you I am now going to make your
day by telling you that before you go to
sleep fine tonight
you must absolutely find this talk on
YouTube and watch it because apart from
anything else it's much better than this
one
and in this talk he pretends it's 1973
and he talks about all of the wonderful
things that are obviously going to
happen in the future of programming
based on all of the wonderful things
that have happened in the 60s when
people were very creative and he's he's
full of you know optimistic certainty
about how programming has become will
you know soon in just a couple of
decades become so much more interesting
and at one point he does say in the talk
he says I am totally confident that in
40 years we won't be writing code in
text files he said I think it would be
kind of a shame if we're still coding in
procedures and text files in sequential
programming models that would suggest
that we didn't learn anything from this
really fertile period in computer
science that would be a tragedy and so
by looking back on the 1960s and
thinking in the future we can see that
the tragedy happened and 40 years later
more than 40 years later we still write
code in text files we're using 1970s
technology as the basis of all of our
tools our whole tool train there's an
opportunity there to do some reinvention
it's problematic because if you want to
do something weird like have a
programming environment that doesn't
save the code in text files then the
whole tool chain that we normally rely
on things like version control suddenly
don't work anymore but surely that would
be a wonderful thing after all as
programmers we love nothing more than
writing code for other programmers
ideally ourselves because this saves us
from having to talk to normal people
non-programmers that's what I mean and
so you'd have to reinvent the whole tool
chain you wouldn't you know you wouldn't
just use the stuff that was basically
developed in the 70s for UNIX you get to
build everything all over again
surely that would be a great I've got a
great benefit of having to start from
scratch I don't know just a thought so
it turns out that there is there are
some new things it's not quite as bleak
as Brett Victor pointed out in 1973 or
in fake in 1973 and so I just wanna
briefly show you a couple of it
for different audiences scratch and bpmn
BPMN is Business Process Model and
notation it's an object management group
standard for modeling and presenting
business process models now it turns out
that there are tools for actually
executing these models so if you've got
some representation of a process and you
can execute it that representation is
essentially code scratch meanwhile is a
visual programming environment for
children it's very popular in in various
places and I guess from about 8 years
old or something it's so completely
accessible approach to programming and
it's really designed for that and it
also uses executable visual code
elements now because of the text on the
elements it's a little bit more obvious
what they do either you have sequences
of instructions that go from top to
bottom now it turns out that both of
these visual notations in different ways
Express basic procedural programming so
you know in you know a box is an action
and you can chain them together in one
way or another and as soon as you have
conditions and loops you can probably do
more or less everything in fact both
languages are richer than that but there
which enough to get into trouble the
main difference is their intended
audience scratch as I said is for
children bpmn is for operations managers
business people people who work with
spreadsheets finance people I guess
another main difference is that scratch
is way more sophisticated of the to
scratch for managers the the bpmn thing
that's that simpler but that's okay
anyway so if you step away from the idea
that code is text files it behaves
differently and you can do a couple of
different things so one of these is the
difference of what you get from zooming
out on your code so we don't see this
kind of zoomed
class on our monitors because this has
pretty much no value and you might have
a little mini-map in your text editor
depending on what you're using but it
doesn't help that much it's not that
meaningful whereas if you zoom out on a
bpmn diagrams slightly too much to be
able to read the text you can still see
some kind of visual structure and you
still have some flexibility about the
layout and so in this in this diagram
that the the five boxes that are
vertically on top of each other that has
some kind of significance that doesn't
mean something there is some kind of
recognizable structure in fact in in
this language code patterns are
literally visual patterns that you
recognize visually and that comes from
the expressivity of doing layout you
have a similar thing in scratch as well
so this program is a bit long and a bit
messy so we can see that already from
zooming out but we can still see the
colors even if we can't read the text we
can see the colors and scratch color
codes different kinds of statements so
this tells us something you can see
where the conditions are where the loops
are even if you can't see what they
actually are so zoom that comes the
thing zoom was never a thing in code
before at least in the kind of code we
use do another thing you can do if
you're not saving the syntax trees
effectively what you're having a code in
programming language if you're not
saving that in text files you can do
things like localize it to different
languages so it doesn't have to be in
English now this is it very important
for 8-year olds because requiring code
to be an English word you know raise the
barrier for getting started and somehow
we have this acceptance as programmers
especially as professional programmers
but it's totally cool if there are huge
learning cliffs on our technology and
huge barriers to getting started but
what if we did all of the things that we
do for kids but for ourselves I mean
surely I mean you know we need to make
it easier for children but why does it
have to be hard for everybody who's not
a child and that's just the beginning
because scratch is part
I mean scratch uses this sort of
web-based visual programming environment
where you're programming what some
characters do and it's got this real
time live debugging thing and the
scratch is kind of sophisticated it
it's some kind of event based real-time
programming environment and you can do
real-time debugging and it's it's it's
super cool there's lots of sophisticated
things going on there and lots of things
that just don't really work if it's on
text files
another thing that's that's wrong or a
missed opportunity was just in text
files is that those text files in the
first instance are probably on your own
laptop whereas scratch is web-based it's
online by default and so if you go to
the scratch website it tells you that
you know you can you can create these
programs these animations these games
whatever and you can share them because
in the top right corner there you can't
see on this picture in in the corner of
the the environment there's a there's a
share button you can share your programs
you've got one-click you know push to
public source code repository and if you
select explore on the website you can
browse currently 32 and a half million
projects now I don't know maybe you're
not impressed because that's that's
barely half the number of repos the
github has but it is for the most part
just children and so I guess 32 and a
half million is quite a large number you
know and I have done this presentation
before and I have to update the number
on the slide it grows quite fast I mean
this is really a thing this is not this
is not a toy in the sense of it's not
real it's a toy in the sense of I guess
we're not building you know business
database applications or a scratch but
you know kids are using it and they get
a lot out of it so that their ability to
be able to view source and copy other
people's code is very important for
learning this is not built into our
normal programming environments because
there's something in the way called git
for many of us
I like language jokes it's a it's a
common thing for English people I guess
an affliction and it turns out that of
course git is an English word I mean
it's colloquial British English it means
a not very nice person which is very
clear description of the usability of
get the programming tool why does it
have to be that hard in scratch
if you see a program that you're
browsing that you're like you click the
remix button that's a one-click fork it
could be that easy so what is the
takeaway from this observation of these
coding environments scratching BPMN and
there are many others especially in the
field of data science especially in
other fields but they do have something
in common it turns out that they are
pretty much always aimed at intended for
people who do not consider themselves to
be programmers and I think there's two
parallel reasons for this one is that if
you want to get kids to do something you
know we understand and accept that it
needs to be as easy as possible if you
want to get you know managers to code
something it needs to be very easy but
it turns out that there's a lot of value
from that Microsoft Excel is also
programming that's most business
programming and you know you can just
you can just get started using it in a
way that you can't with the kind of
programming we do and of course the
other problem is that if you push these
kind of visual programming environments
towards conventional professional
programmers which is most of us we tend
to reject it immediately and I'm not
sure if it's because we want to stay in
the 1970s or because we think it's not
real programming but calling something
not real programming is mostly just a
sign that you're being an and
not allowing other people to you know
enjoy programming as well because these
other things including Microsoft Excel
are absolutely real programming you know
be more inclusive in your communities so
all of the innovation is for these
reasons you know we're not getting it
it's going elsewhere so what does that
mean for us well what I think it might
mean for us and this worries me a little
bit is it's related to this this is a
photo of an 80 column
now I'm not old enough to have actually
seen one of these
certainly not to have ever written code
on one of these but my rough high-level
understanding is that you punch holes in
them and that represents binary encoded
numbers that represent machine code
instructions on the machine you're gonna
feed the card into we don't use these
anymore I can't even imagine trying to
program using these it just must have
been absolutely horrible so when these
were when machine language programming
was replaced with well not replaced when
assembly language was introduced the
people who did machine code programming
they said well that's not real
programming this is real you know you
got a write machine code I mean how do
you even know what's going on if you are
assembly language but inevitably the
convenience one and assembly language
you know became popular I mean people
hold operating systems in it but at a
certain point high level languages like
C were introduced and of course what did
the assembly language programmers say
they said that's not real programming
how do you know what's even going on
what if the C programmers say about
garbage collection so the cycle repeats
itself and we get these newer
programming languages and discussing old
versus new shiny versus less shiny
programming languages seems to occupy a
lot of our time as programmers we argue
about which programming language we
should we use when I run a local
community meetup and completely novice
programmers turn up or people who want
to switch to programming turn up they
always ask what programming language
should I use and this usually generates
quite a long-winded discussion amongst
the old and jaded programmers who are
present because usually it starts off
with somebody saying it doesn't matter
somebody else said well yeah it doesn't
matter but you shouldn't use JavaScript
and this sort of continues for a very
long time until there's this kind of
rough consensus at the end that you
should probably use Python I don't know
because it's something it's friendly yes
but all of the programming languages
were arguing about are in some very real
sense all copies of either Lisp or
Fortran in text files and so arguing
about whether your language
and I hang around in the Java community
a lot in the Java community you know
there's this joke that Java is the new
Cobalt but that's entirely missing the
point worrying about whether is that
true is c-sharp safe or is c-sharp also
the new COBOL you're entirely missing
the point that's not what you should
worry about you should absolutely worry
about writing code printed on the
typewriter in ASCII text files being the
new punch cards because when the kids
who've grown up on scratch you know
graduated from their computer science
degrees and start startups to make the
next generation of programming languages
and development environments they're not
going to want to stick with this they're
going to invent some kind of enterprise
scratch and I have no idea what that is
going to look like but I do know from
the talk this morning that anything
after you know anything I experienced
knew after 35 is going to seem to me
against the natural order of things I'm
gonna have problem adjusting to that so
if we stick with our ASCII text files
we're basically sticking with punch
cards and we're sticking with the
typewriter and the next generation is
just going to take all of our jobs and
we'll be out of work and we'll be sad so
we have an opportunity to you know I
don't to end on that kind of sad note
because that's got about but we do have
an opportunity to think about more
interesting kinds of programming tools
to recognize and notice that there are
lots of communities who are
non-conventional programmers using some
really cool tools and maybe we should
get in on that and maybe push the work
out how can we modernize our tools so
that we're no longer essentially writing
code on a typewriter thanks very much
would anybody like to ask questions in
front of everybody else or you can just
come and talk to me while I'm packing on
my laptop I don't see any hands okay